this video is sponsored by blinkist
emil taran was a writer and philosopher
born in 1911
and what is present day rasanari romania
he is renowned for his penetratingly
dark
nihilistic yet beautiful writing style
considered by many to be one of the
great writers of despair
building his philosophical arguments off
the somber emotional rhythm of his prose
often expressing shocking thoughts and
dark humor nearly every sentence and
passage
hung down from the very heights of
despair
born into a socially and spiritually
volatile time of western history
somewhere in the middle of the
increasing disintegration of traditional
religious ideology
and the newly emerging philosophical
movements of existentialism
idealism and other pessimistic schools
of thought tyron would find himself
positioned on the face of a mountain
that humanity was desperately trying to
get over and from his view
he saw nothing a deathly climb to
another valley of nowhere
[Music]
at a fairly young age charon would
become a heavy reader going on to study
literature and philosophy
at the university of bucharest a public
university in romania
here he would study and read the works
of philosophers like emmanuel kant
friedrich nietzsche arthur schopenhauer
lev shestoff
hegel and many others at 23 he would
publish his first book
titled on the heights of despair which
would soon go on to receive
controversial but mostly positive
critical acclaim
achieving him two notable awards and
setting him on the path to soon become
an internationally recognized writer and
thinker
in this first work not only did charon
reveal his promising young intellectual
mind
but also what would go on to become the
recurring lifelong themes and obsessions
of his work
themes like despair suffering social
isolation
absurdity futility failure decay and
death
written out of a spell of horrible
insomnia this first book would provide a
foretelling of what awaited charon
a lifelong exploration of the underbelly
of the human condition
fueled by a depression-infused insomniac
lifestyle
i've never been able to write otherwise
than in the midst of the depression
brought about by my knights of insomnia
tehran writes
for seven years i could barely sleep i
need this depression
and even today before i sit down to
write i play a disc of gypsy music
from hungary like many great writers and
artists
tehran felt as though he had to write it
was not as if he made his work sad
but that his sadness made his work in
the moments of depression
writing was according to him his only
therapy
his first book and the 20 plus others of
his to come according to tehran
saved him from what might have otherwise
seemed like the logical conclusion to
much of his work
if nothing else this aspect of his work
and life reveals a profound insight into
the potency of the creative process
that even in writing about the futility
and meaninglessness of life
and its endeavors the power of the
creative process can
in some sense save the writer from the
very substance and content of their own
work
paradoxically making the futility and
meaninglessness that they discuss
somewhat less futile and meaningless
after leaving romania for the last time
in 1940 tron would end up living the
majority of his life in paris
he would go on to produce upwards of 20
books written in both romanian and
french
keeping the same eloquence wit and
intensity throughout
his work would increasingly develop and
maintain him a highly respected
reputation
amongst the prominent french
intellectual scene garnering the
admiration of high-ranking philosophical
peers
as well as a large following of readers
across the world
despite this he would live a very modest
private life going to great lengths to
avoid any and all
accolades and any way of life that would
otherwise be considered ordinarily
successful
in 1995 at the age of 84 charon died
after having developed alzheimer's
several years prior slowly but surely
one of the most eloquent minds of the
20th century
lost all relationship with words and
then experienced the main theme of his
life's work
firsthand
in terms of turon's philosophy despite
his work being unmistakably perceptive
and intelligent
he is somewhat interesting and perhaps
debatable in the context of a
philosopher
for the most part traditional
philosophical work is almost always
grounded in a particular system of
thought
which is formed or integrated first as a
foundation
and then logically built on from there
chiron's work however
does not really start from nor integrate
any real system of this form
rather it relies more on his aphoristic
observational writing style
which seems to almost philosophize and
reveal metaphysical ideas
through the emotionally tense subjective
and chaotic reading experience alone
without much consideration for logical
structure or systematic reasoning
seeing as how a key part of toronto's
philosophy is that he disagreed with the
premise of reason
and traditional philosophy as a means of
resolving life and explaining its
reasonlessness
this approach arguably makes sense to
adequately argue for a philosophy of
absurdity and reasonlessness
what better way is there than to write
without priority for structure
or reason and in this sense perhaps it
would be more accurate to say that
tehran
is sort of an anti-philosophy
philosopher which perhaps nonetheless is
ironically still a philosophy
[Music]
according to what can be surmised of
tehran's views it is more or less death
specifically
that both causes the futility of life
and poses the inevitable limit to all
reason
within it however in his most famous
work
the trouble with being born he discusses
how since death necessarily follows from
birth
it is actually the memory of our birth
that is the tragic problem of life
and not death in and of itself the
attempt to reason an understanding or
solution to the conscious awareness of
death
stemming from birth is thus both the
driving force of philosophy
religion and science and simultaneously
their collapsing force
the unbeatable opponent under which all
reason logic and human effort
crumble and consequently any
philosophical attempt to do so
for charon can only be a contemplation
on failure broadly speaking
this concept would also become a
fundamental tenet of his philosophy
often underpinning his ideas on the
notion that human endeavors are almost
always synonymous
and faded with failure what his work
also seemed to parallel alongside this
dread and nihilism though
is the notion of accepting and playing
into the absurdity of it all
loving the absurd uselessness for what
it is how it is
and using it against itself and living
anyway
in the words of tehran when all the
current reasons moral
aesthetic religious social and so on no
longer guide one's life
how can one sustain life without
succumbing to nothingness
only by a connection with the absurd by
love of absolute uselessness
loving something which does not have
substance but which simulates an
illusion of life
i live because the mountains do not
laugh and the worms do not sing
it is in this dive into the absurdity
that sharon seems to pose the question
can those who accept and embrace failure
and disaster
ever really fail or be struck by either
pessimism in this sense
almost serves as a trump card the last
true failure being the failure of
optimism
from there we become as he put it
invincible victims
there is a certain unique and important
quality to the irony of turan's work
as a sort of anti-philosophy philosopher
who argued that life cannot be made or
reasoned
into any sort of reconciliation or
meaningful benefit
he nonetheless did so by philosophizing
at least in some form nihilism of which
he is generally associated
denies the value of all things but can
annihilus philosophy
be expressed as a philosophy and remain
a nihilist philosophy
in other words can the premise and
conclusion be that life is inherently
meaningless
and that endeavoring and seeking reason
is entirely futile
while simultaneously making this
meaningful claim through creative action
and albeit subversive providing reasons
for it
discussing or creatively expressing the
notion that all is meaningless and void
of reason
is itself a creation of meaning out of
the void
motivated by the very void of reason the
process of forming meaning it seems
can perhaps not be escaped even by one
of the greatest so-called nihilists
and perhaps then at bottom charan is
never really declaring true nihilism
there is the more obvious reading of
tehran and perhaps others like him
that can reasonably come off as if it
was created by someone who outright
hates life
and lives with the constant bitterness
towards everyone and everything
but there is also another read that
seemingly reveals a paradoxical
reverence and embrace
of life although tehran might not have
explicitly agreed with this
to speak of life with such candor in the
way he did to think it is worthy to be
spoken of at all
to refuse to lie to it or about it
despite how dark or bleak it might be
perhaps suggests a certain hidden but
nonetheless deep admiration
and acceptance of it when asked once why
he writes about such dismal topics in
the way he does
tehran said everything that is
formulated becomes more tolerable
his work time and time again
demonstrates this revealing the perhaps
vile and horribly unresolvable qualities
of life while simultaneously revealing
the potential for redemption contained
inside them
a worthiness of enduring of thinking of
writing
of living life cursed with the gift of
consciousness
we are all inescapably forced into the
beautiful confrontation of the void
and the absurd inevitability of creating
meaning and somethingness out of it
tron's work is likely not for everyone
but for those whom it is
it is likely with a great degree as all
art and literature arguably should
his work attempts to reflect with as
much brute earnestness as possible
the things most of us know and feel but
are often too scared or unsure
to not only talk about but think about
he was one of the rare explorers
willing or perhaps forced into traveling
through the depths of hell
and heights of despair and then tell
about it
perhaps tron's work can be seen simply
as a collection of life-refusing
nihilistic thoughts
or perhaps it can also be seen as an
embodiment of the irrational
but no less potent force of human
creative consciousness at work
its ability to meaningfully endure even
its own horrible conditions
and in this in his works arguably
successful confrontation and embracing
of the sad
hopeless and absurd parts of life it
serves as an enduring and important
connection point into these often hidden
but deeply shared human experiences
reminding us that we aren't so alone
and reassuring us with the comforting
notion that
i'm simply an accident why take it all
so seriously
[Music]
amiotaran
this video was sponsored by blinkist
perhaps one of the hardest parts in
developing and maintaining consistent
strong reading habits
is sifting through the sheer amount of
quality nonfiction books available out
there
the book summary service blinkist makes
this much easier by condensing complete
books down into around 15 minutes
summaries
providing their main ideas and key
takeaways in a convenient amount of time
hitting just about anyone's interests
blinkist covers thousands of non-fiction
books
in subjects spanning from different
areas of philosophy and psychology
to science and technology to
productivity in art and much more
if you're interested in topics related
to psychology or the creative process
blinkist has a great selection of titles
including the blank slate by stephen
pinker
which explores an evolutionary
psychology view of human nature
and flow by mihai chiksatmihai which
explores the conditions and functions of
creativity as well as its role in
dealing with anxiety
and meaninglessness blinkist not only
makes it easier and more efficient to
consume books information
but can also help save you time when
determining if a book or author
is what you are looking for prior to
reading the full version
or perhaps refreshing yourself on a book
after all book summaries can be read or
listened to conveniently within the
blinkist app
and for books that you find you are more
interested in you can now purchase the
complete audiobook versions for certain
titles
directly within the app as well the
first 100 people to use the link in the
description
will receive one free week of unlimited
access as well as 25
off a premium membership the free 7-day
trial can be canceled at any time within
the trial period
if you're interested please visit
blinkist.com pursuit of wonder or click
the link in the description below
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you